so as we continue our discussion on
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four we
pick up now with the Fantastic Four
issue number 579 now this I guess this
in issue number 580 these are what we
call filler issues these are not wildly
important to the overall happenings of
hitman's Fantastic Four but the reason
why we're covering them is because there
are events that will transpire later on
in his run of the Fantastic Four that
will require us to know about this the
first is that spider-man will become
part of the events but also Doctor Doom
will become part of the events but the
other half of this is that Hickman is
going to launch a story called the
future foundation and the Future
Foundation will basically be a tie-in to
his run of the Fantastic Four and it'll
be like Batman with Detective Comics
where it gives us the other half of
what's going on with regards to the
events as they're transpiring now with
this story what we're told is that Reed
Richards has journeyed to Golden
Colorado to pick up with something
called a singularity conference now the
singularity conference does actually
exist I wouldn't say this is something
like TED talk but as far as I understand
it is basically a research conference it
involves some of the top minds that
focus on artificial intelligence now
again I'm not really knowledgeable about
it so I can't offer too much on that
discussion but what I can say is that
within the Marvel Universe as far as
Jonathan Hickman's run of the Fantastic
Four is concerned the the singularity
conference was created by Reed Richards
in Marvel Comics and he was designed for
the purpose of bringing the world's top
scientific minds together to basically
solve the world's problems to move the
world in a more progressive and prolific
direction but the issue here is that
Reed Richards has yet to see this
conference do this and what I mean is
that as he's talking to them of course
he praises she-hulk for the fact that
you know being in the the legal
profession she's basically written
articles about the laws of artificial
intelligence about the laws of
Technology and how they relate to what
goes on in the world at the moment
before read this was designed to
genuinely be a technological masterpiece
but instead of being bad the individuals
who were part of the singularity
conference have basically allowed their
politics to run the show instead of
writing articles instead of focusing on
is artificial intelligence a realistic
goal or our advances in technology a
realistic goal is turned into an
argument of
is artificial intelligence and is
technology are those realistic goals
insofar as their political views about
religion and I guess you know various
social issues around the country and the
result is that reads basically come to
the belief that they've all failed at
their their tasks they've all failed a
conference and they failed their purpose
and so what Reed Richards ends up doing
is he doesn't really disassemble the
entire concept of the singularity
conference instead he leaves he
basically quits he walks away and says
that everything is all said and done and
so the following week what we do is you
pick up with his arrival back at the
Baxter building now we're not really
told what he was doing during this time
and we don't really need to know but
what is important here is that after
talking to Johnny storm after talking to
the various members of the Fantastic
Four and just kind of associating with
them and being welcomed back what we're
told is that he's basically reached out
to the smartest people or the smartest
children and the in the Marvel Universe
so he's reached out to his own children
Franklin and valaria now I wouldn't say
Franklin is one of the smartest people
in the world but because of the fact
that he's a child of Reed Richards of
course Reed Richards is going to bring
his son into the fold bubble area as we
discussed is genuinely extremely
intelligent she's as smart as as Reed
Richards if not smarter depending on
what it is that's going on but the
reason why she has the edge and the
reason why all these other kids are
brought in as part of the part of this
this group is because they have
imagination they're not restricted by
politics they're not restricted by how
they want the world to be restricted
they're restricted by how they look at
the world and so to them there is no
limit anything can happen anything can
be done and this is exactly what Reed
was looking for and so after talking to
these various individuals I've been
talking to the various students and
Wyndham asking the question why are they
all there what Reed says is that they
are the Future Foundation they're there
to basically help him solve the problem
of everything but more so than that to
basically look to the future to look to
the horizon and to move the world into a
better direction now the reason why I
brought this up this is actually kind of
a sub story this is a Side Story that's
actually pretty interesting later on
down the line and it will tie in to
Reed's failing and attempting to solve
the problem everything is basically the
events of
for those of you guys who have looked at
Ben Grimm historically as a character
that's routinely been a part of the
Fantastic Four and always fought
alongside them you may see him in a
couple different ways you may see him as
a character who's basically just kind of
the comedic relief he cracks his jokes
and he calls it a day you may look at
him as the strong guy of the team he
basically is the hired nut were the
hired muscle he's basically the the
muscle of the team he does what the
other members of the team can do when it
comes to sheer strength but one of the
major cornerstones of Ben Grimm's
character is that he's always struggled
with the fact that he can never go back
to the way he was before now there have
been attempts made by Reed Richards to
basically cure him but they've always
failed and in some of some instances
they've been catastrophic in the sense
that they've completely changed the way
Ben Grimm looks at in fact if you go
look at some of the John Byrne artistry
on the Fantastic Four there was one
point in time whereby his physical
appearance became very edgy and very
rocky in the sense that instead of
looking kind of smooth the way he does
now he had a lot of sharp edges and the
reason why is because that was a result
of Reed Richards meddling around and
attempting to cure him and so what
happens here is the first task of the
future foundation is to try to cure Ben
Grimm and this is one of the coolest
things about this because this is
Hickman basically telling us it again
these kids have unbridled imagination
there's no limit to what they can do but
more so than that they're better working
as a group than they are as individuals
and this again highlights the limit of
Reed Richards Reed Richards is just one
man he can only look at the world
through his own eyes but with a group of
kids who have unlimited imagination
putting their minds to task they can
effectively solve anything and what we
find out is that valaria begins speaking
with Ben Grimm and they initially
present the idea of returning him back
to his human form of basically making
him normal again but Ben Grimm again
shied away from it just because of his
checkered past with Reed Richards
attempting to do this and so what we're
told by both Franklin and valaria and a
couple other kids is that the problem
with Reed Richards trying to cure Ben
Grimm is he wasn't looking at Ben Grimm
for what he was he was looking at Ben
Grimm's entire change as something on
the surface as opposed to a fundamental
change and this is actually really cool
because Hickman gives us a little bit of
modification on the powers of the
Fantastic Four for the longest time when
the Fantastic Four had their abilities
Reed Richards stretching Johnny Storm
being able to you know set himself on
fire and so on and so forth you know we
always had this notion that maybe it was
just something that
read and that Susan storm and the Johnny
storm could control they tapped into
some aspect of their brain and they were
able to manifest these things but what
the what hitman tells us do through the
Future Foundation is that this is not
the case that basically Johnny Storm
Susan storm and Reed Richards have like
an on/off switch for their powers but
there's still a genetic part of who they
are so when it comes down to the very
fundamental the core level of the
Fantastic Four in a lot of ways they're
no different than the x-men the only
difference here is that instead of a
gene activating that caused their powers
instead they were their bodies were
modified on the on the genetic level and
so the result is that Ben Grimm does not
have this on-off switch he doesn't have
the ability to modify his genetic code
and so what Franklin Richards and what
valaria Richards and the rest of the
Future Foundation do is they basically
say that they've come up with a way for
him to do this they've come up with a
way for him to effectively turn his
power off and what they do is they
present him with a with a substance with
a chemical of sorts that he can consume
and that will make him human for only
one week now this is extremely important
and the reason why is because in the
next video and what we're actually going
to do in the next few discussions or so
is one we're going to talk about the
death of Johnny Storm but - once we get
further into this and we actually get
into nathaniel richards visiting Reed
Richards again we're going to learn that
there's actually a lot more to this
substance and not only is it going to
make Ben Grimm human for a week it's
actually going to have unforeseen
consequences and this is gonna you know
again be Hickman's Way of telling us
that Reed Richards doesn't know
everything and despite the fact that he
has a future foundation and despite the
fact that these kids are all working
together in the end they're actually
going to screw up the life of Ben Grimm
they're going to you know they're going
to basically destroy it then Grimm
doesn't know it they don't know it and
they won't know it for a little while
but it's actually a really cool series
of events and it's actually really
interesting the way this whole this
whole little bit unfolds and again I
really consider this to be just a great
element of hickman storytelling it's
just a cornerstone of storytelling this
thread doesn't go anywhere it just shows
us how things will turn out in a future
point in time however following this
what we do is we pick up with valaria
Richards a short time later when she
goes to visit Doctor Doom now this
little bit of the story actually
requires some expansion on a few
previously existing concepts they're not
wildly important but they give us an
idea of what's going on during an event
called the fall of hooks which dealt
with a group called the intelligentsia
what we were told is that at some point
prior to most of the large events have
been going on in Marvel Comics some of
the smartest super villains in the
history of Marvel Comics had basically
banded together as a sort of Illuminati
a scheme of their own and they had
planned world domination and different
things like that but they were
responsible for the creation of Red Hulk
and so on and so forth but the fact
remains that dr. doom had been a part of
their plan to basically take over
everything but during this conflict as
part of fall of Hookes alpha dr. doom
had been captured alongside Reed
Richards and a handful of other
superheroes who were considered to be
the top eight smartest individuals on
the planet Earth which is actually where
that list comes from people talk about
the smartest individuals of Marvel
Comics and what had happened was dooms
intelligence had effectively been
siphoned off now we didn't initially
know this and in fact we didn't really
know the outcome of it all we knew was
that doom had seemed to have been shaken
up by everything that was going on and
so what happens is that as Valyria
Richards is making her way out of the
Baxter building she stumbles across the
laboratory of Reed Richards and the
portal that he created but granted him
access to the council of Reed's and what
happens is she basically begins going
over the holographic logs of Reed
Richards where he talks about everything
that had happened and what valaria
learns is that not only was retrying to
solve the problem of everything but she
also learns that he that she can
basically access this particular portal
and so what happens here and this
actually takes place off panel though we
find out later on what I'll have taken
place she basically accesses the portal
and so what happens is that once she's
done she leaves and she comes back to
converse with dr. doom now once we pick
up with doom he's basically reflecting
on how his intelligence had been
siphoned away by the Intelligencia and
because the fact that he's partially
damaged he basically reaches out for the
purpose of taking his adopted son
Christoph Bernard and assimilating the
intelligence of Christoph Bernard and in
turn basically using him to restore
himself now this tells us how sinister
and how dark dr. doom is but it also
makes him really cool I can't tell you
exactly why but there's something to be
said about dr. doom willing to just kill
in
some people for the purpose of ensuring
his own legacy of ensuring that he
continues on but before this plan can be
fleshed out before he can decide what it
is they do next
Valyria Richards appears and so what
happens issue begins talking to dr.
doone now something to keep in mind here
is that when valaria Richards was born
to Susan storm valaria Richards and
Susan were going through birth
complications and it was actually dr.
doom that effectively saved her life
they made it possible for valaria to be
born and so he's sort of an uncle to her
he's basically a very close member to
her but even more so than that and this
is why I love Hickman's writing so much
is because she looks at him not really
as a role model but as a person whose
intelligence is equal to if not
occasionally a little bit less than her
own and so because of that when it comes
to the mind he's an equal to her and so
she views him as maybe somebody she can
consult and that's what she's doing here
because of the fact that the future
Franklin Richard had appeared to valaria
and said all hope lies in doom she's
basically fulfilling this pact she's
finding out what it is or why it is that
all hope lies with him now again she
doesn't know how the future is going to
turn out but her logic dictates that if
the future version of Franklin was going
to come to the past and tell her all
hope lies with doom then she better go
visit dr. doom and so what is up
happening here is that dr. doom of
course she explains what all had gone on
with her father with Reed Richards
creating a portal that allowed him to
access the Council of reeds and when dr.
doom asked what it is she found when she
went through the portal but she shows us
that some of the reeds had been killed
that this council of reeds that this
temple had basically been in total
shambles and what she tells us is that
the Council of Reed's have effectively
been destroyed in their entirety or at
least they appear to have been destroyed
in their entirety but she also says and
this is actually a very very important
thing she also says that there are a
whole bunch of versions of dr. doom that
seemed to have been lobotomized and
they're just living below the the
facility itself the council chamber
itself and so when she travels into the
end of the building
she actually discovers that the man
Celestials are still there and the
battle is still raging on albeit with
whatever few forces happen to be left
behind and so while these versions of
Reed are doing what they can in the end
again it's just not enough because we're
talking about entities from a different
reality that possess Universal level
power that possess astronomical power
and so what is up happening here is well
as completely text list well we don't
really know everything that's going on
we know the valeri is trying to help
them that most likely she talked to them
but we're not given the full explanation
of what all had taken place and this is
actually interesting I'm not really sure
why a Jonathan Hickman chose to go this
route I wouldn't go as far as to say it
was a bad decision
it's just his the effect that he was
looking for was kind of lost on me when
I was going through this but what what
she tells dr. doom is that in the end
Reed made the wrong choice and this is
actually really interesting because had
valaria made the decision things would
have been vastly different and we
actually would have seen the future of
Franklin coming to fruition but what she
says here is that her father had the
choice which we saw be the problem of
humanity or else basically keeping his
family and because Reed chose to stay
with his family because he chose not to
take the same road that all the other
reads in the Council of Reed's chose
which was to basically abandon their
families that in the end he made their
own choice and he screwed up but more so
than that was funny with this is that
Valerius says that she notices something
is off about dr. doom now she does not
know about the fall of Hulk storyline
she does not know about those events as
far as I'm aware all she knows is that
by virtue of the fact that a dr. doom is
twitching a bit in one of his hands
because of the fact that he is
perspiring because of the fact that he's
showing characteristics that do not
exceed the normal kind of confidence
that he puts off complete control the
situation that something's not quite
right and valaria immediately deduces
that he has brain damage and so the
agreement the two of them strike is that
she will find a way to cure dr. Doom's
brain damage if dr. doom agrees to
basically help Reed Richards whenever
the time comes when that help is needed
now we will actually find this out later
on following the death of Johnny Storm
and dr. doom is actually going to join
the Future Foundation which creates it
makes some really cool storytelling it
creates some really cool dichotomy
between himself and the rest of the
Fantastic Four and the superheroes but
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and wrap this up and let me know
what you guys think about Hickman's
Fantastic Four so far and I will catch
you all later peace